if you've been watching our show you
know i'm feeling extra thankful this
year
and i'm clearly not afraid to express
my gratitude
[Music]
see sam did this preset that's why it
looks ten times better good for you sam
making me look good but i gotta give you
all the credit
this detail the hands actually i can't
even take credit for that
i thought we might have been like a
sarah or an alex peter grumbine who's
like one of our heads at digital with
the show cause i was like i'll just put
my instagram like account into the show
like he's like no no that's not how this
works
you say you be you in your world
he always says trust your gut i'm glad
i've had someone who said that very
advice to me
thank you elaine for believing in me and
challenging me she's not a yes man
a good follow is food 52 on instagram
sammy lee harris
thank you arturo i mean i really do love
this incredible crew that puts this show
together
every day can you tell by how i
obsessively talk about them and love all
up on them
what can you count on each day that
gives you inspiration for the show
you know what it's the crew and the team
it's true i want to make sure everyone
who's working on the show
feels good and settled and then i feel
good and subtle i have so much fun with
the news crew
the best people in the world the best
crew in the world that i'm so lucky
to yeah that's right guys
and ladies that's right cindy i'm
looking at you oh we have our fantastic
crew
i love you guys so much well i'm also
thankful for everyone who has supported
this show this year
especially our incredible vff and we
also have our virtual friends
hello look at these humans in this brand
new technology
and you are virtual family and friends
vffs
thank you so much you guys
i just i love hanging out with everyone
and to everyone
else in my personal life
thank you for watching today happy
thanksgiving from
all of us at the drewberrymore show
whether you're
part of the show team a virtual friend
contributor
guest or viewer you all make
our show a family and we appreciate you
so this is the crew that makes this
happen
hayden take it away hey i'm hayden i'm
the culprit compliance officer
i'm chris i'm the production coordinator
i'm melissa i'm a production assistant
i'm sorry i'm an inspection assistant
i'm emily i'm an ap
hi i'm chip art department freelancer hi
i'm rachel i'm epa
and i'm drew who's lucky enough to work
with this amazing team
everybody keeps saying thank you for the
puppies but guess who we have today
yeah sammy sullivan
ken thank you
thank you arch thank you ken
[Music]
did you practice the wedding
[Music]
we still have our jobs we're not quiet
[Applause]
[Music]
i love you guys thank you so much
for contributing your beauty and your
energy and your goodness
to the show thank you thank you thank
[Music]
you
you